hello everyone and welcome to a most
amazing game that was suggested to me
today via email uh it's a game between a
grand master and a feed a master now
sometimes uh lower rated players will
just obliterate uh top Grand Masters
like we've seen in a couple of my
previous videos that I've made and those
games can be very very interesting but
sometimes it's just not the case and it
wasn't the case in this game it was a
game from the 44th Olympiad uh played in
China and it's a game between Grand
Master at home fausty and a fide Master
yeah now uh you you guys will absolutely
love this game it's been a while since
we've had a game uh this awesome it's uh
I I was thinking about including it in
my sorcery series but uh I don't know it
just doesn't feel right adding modern
games to the sorcery series like if I
found a a game that was this crazy from
let's say 19 1900s I I would include it
but I don't know it's hard to say you
know how much is engine preparation how
much is actually over the board
inspiration as well as just enjoy the
game and then you guys can decide
whether it belongs there or not and uh
we've had some incredible games by uh
favsy already I think I've covered two
of his games and both of them were
really awesome I will put a link to them
in the description below if you want to
check it out after the video or maybe
even before this video uh it's up to you
so let's check it out outcome has the
white pieces and he opens with Ponte E4
we have Pawn to C5
uh performing goes for the Sicilian
Defense with Knight to F3 E6 and now
Pawn to D4 so just striking in the
center captures captures and now Pawn to
A6 this is the con variation and uh it
uh can
um create some very exciting positions
we have Bishop to D3 continuing
development you know that Knight to F6
is coming so it makes sense to have the
pawn defended Knight to F6 castles and
now Queen to C7 and here uh the standard
idea is Queen to E2 but in the game we
have Bishop to E3 and this is a a setup
um uh you know enjoyed by many uh many
attackers uh as you know Paul Murphy
also loved putting his Bishops on D3 and
E3 and so does a Autumn as it seems we
have pawned the five striking against D4
Pawn Knight to C3 and now D captures an
E4 Knight captures and now just Knight B
to D7 and there are a couple of games
that read you this position known moves
are some like Queen T two Knight
captures and F6 spawn the C3 but in this
game we have Pawn to C4 and it is now as
of move 10 that we have a completely new
game so let's see what happens here uh
Knight captures on e4 makes sense um
here um
a better problem is saying I would very
much love capturing here and then
winning a temple with Knight to F6
because your bishop and E4 will be
hanging so that's exactly what happens
captures captures Knight to F6 attacks
the bishop and now Bishop comes back to
F3 with Bishop to E7 preparing the
castle and uh you know remember this for
the rest of the game Bishop t7 preparing
the castle and here at home plays the
move that you never want to see on the
board he plays Pawn to C5 and this is
just so annoying uh it's a move yeah I
mean your opponent is not defended and
you can capture it with the queen and
the bishop but you really can't if you
capture it with the bishop Rook the C1
just wins the game on the spot uh
doesn't even matter if you move the
queen because B4 of course is coming if
you move the queen let's say t7 then
comes Knight to E5 attacks the queen
attacks the bishop twice and there's
nothing to do if Captain F5 Bishop
captures and C5 attacks the queen
prevents the king from castling Rook FT1
is coming it's a game over so capturing
with the bishop is out of the question
capturing with the queen not much better
just Knight capture on E6 opens up a
double Discovery denied captures on G7
and Black's entire position is ruined so
uh the best thing for you to do after
Pawn to C5 is the move that you prepared
with Bishop t7 best movies to just
Castle here and okay then you maybe face
Pawn to C6 but then you decide what to
play let's say Knight to D5 and okay
everything is perfectly fine
however after the spawn the C5 move uh
We've Pawn to E5 by purple and now comes
a queen to A4 with check with Bishop to
D7 and now another annoying move
preventing peppering from castling Pawn
to C6 how do you how do you face this uh
well B captures on C6 it's a good move
as any and now you'd expect something
like Knight captures or Bishop captures
even but no Knight the F5 and what is
this what is Knight to F5 what what is
he doing well of course if Bishop
captures an F5 then you leave the C6
Pawn undefender then Bishop captures
with check or even Queen characters in
C6 with check forces you to trade
because now the queen is hanging and if
you trade then Bishop captures with
check and then you pick up the Rook on
the next move so instead after Knight to
F5 Pawn the C5 was played attacking the
queen here and it seems like you
shouldn't be able to capture on G7 with
check because then King to f8 and your
knight will be hanging and also the
queen will be hanging but now look at
this Knight captures on G7 with check I
think the f8 and now how do you continue
Bishop to H6 and now
uh black really does not have all that
many options uh the absolute best move
is to capture the queen so Bishop
captures an A4 but now Knight the E6
with check this is a double check so you
have to flee uh King to G8 and now
Knight captures on C7 winning back the
queen not The Rook an A8 is hanging we
have rooked the A7 attacking the Knight
and now uh my absolute favorite move of
the game you'd think that the the you
know the temporary Queen sacrifice would
be my favorite move but no this is my
favorite move and that is a rook to E1
finding Rook after E1 really makes you a
tal-like attacker because you have to
I like really all you have to think
about is how to Checkmate that black
king and then you find Rook fd1 now the
point is if Rook captures on C7 then
Rook captures an E5 threatens mate in
one and the only way to defend this well
not the only way but the only maybe
reasonable way is Knight the E8 now okay
you can you can defend uh button and the
G5 score is covered by the bishop but
now look at this Rook 8 to E1 now
preparing Rook captures on E7 and now
you don't really have all that much
Knight to G7 will have to be played you
will give back some material here
captures captures and captures and the
white is up only one Pawn but the white
position is much more active white has
the bishop pair the Super Active Rook on
the seventh Rank and the black will have
to wait a few more moves before getting
that Rook into the game if it will it at
all be possible okay for the moment you
can't really if the Knight moves you can
play Rook d8 because the bishop covers
that but uh
it's not going to be easy to develop so
instead after Rook after E1 we have
pawned the E form challenging the bishop
Here and Now another beautiful move
Knight the D5 again saying that you
don't care okay obviously if you capture
the bishop here then the bishop on E7
hangs but what happens if you just
capture the Knight well if you just
capture the Knight then Rook captures an
E4 again threatens to Checkmate Rook to
G4 check you're gonna have to block with
the bishop and then Rook captures and G5
will be Checkmate so here you would have
to play Bishop to C2 to attack the uh
The Rook here and well this was in fact
played in the game but the problem is uh
if you play something like Bishop to D7
which also stops Checkmate then Rook to
D1 would happen and look at this now uh
the the Knight cannot move if you play
Bishop to E6 which of course is just
silly dangerous Rook characters on D5
and again Bishop cannot capture because
of Rook to G4 and if you try something
else like Bishop to f8 which is your
only move then we just trade Bishop
countress King captures Rock capture Sun
D5 and again the game continues with
white being much more active uh the
bishop to C6 of course is impossible due
to Rook 38 and uh
uh White will have an excellent game but
and this might even be the the top line
for black this weird line that we've
shown but in the game Bishop the C2 was
played now comes to Rook to G4 with
check Bishop to G6 that was the idea
behind Bishop to C2 now comes Bishop
characters on D5 winning the material
back and finally Bishop to f8 we have
Bishop back to E3 and now Bishop to G7
putting pressure on the B2 Pawn but here
just Pawn to H4 saying that you don't
really care about this because then Pawn
to H5 is happening uh or in other words
Bishop captures and B2 are just gonna
attack the bishop and now you would love
to go back so H5 doesn't hurt you but if
you go back uh then Rook the B8 check
and that's it Bishop to f8 you just play
H5 or even better Bishop to H6 you just
get checkmated uh that's it black would
resign here so after Pawn to H4 Rook to
D7 is played sort of preparing Bishop to
B2
uh but now just Bishop to B3 and now it
seems that you will be able to capture
on beat you because there is no Rook to
be one followed by Rook to B8 with check
uh but you'd only think that Bishop
characters on B2 is played and now Rook
to E1 uh with Bishop to C3 attacking The
Rook Rook to C1 and now Bush back to B2
Rook captures on C5 now threatening Rook
to C2 with check amongst other things
and now King The f8 King The G7 probably
a little bit better but uh you just lose
a piece if you remember the G file so
King to f8 was played for that reason
but now Ponte H5 and you don't care we
don't win the bishop because you will
take away the G file from the black king
Bishop to B1 uh had to be played and now
comes Rook the C8 with check and he was
in this position on move 33 that
particularly Macaulay resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
now it seems like you will be able to
defend because if King the E7 The Rook
is capped after the bishop will capture
Bank the problem is if the king moves to
E7 you will first give a bishop to C5
check which now forces the king to F6
King to F6 will be played now the king
blocks The Bishop's defense of the rook
and I just Rook captures and h8 will
capture a full rook and of course
there's no point in continuing this fact
of The Rook to see it with the check uh
performing resigned and another
spectacular Victory uh for atom fazi in
this remarkable game in the 44th
Olympiad that was played in Chennai last
year so yeah I haven't seen this game
even though it was played last year but
that's the problem no one suggested it
up until then now you suggested the meme
and I am very very happy that it was and
that I was able to share this
masterpiece with you guys and if you
enjoyed this game I also very much
encourage you to check out two other
games by atham uh first links in the
description below uh you you guys will
enjoy them so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank amazing
AMD Verizon Enthusiast group and
golfsoftware.com for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of everything
that's happening in the Chess World and
of course checking up on your uh
wonderful suggestions such as this one
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day